et notre premier invité c'est donc
philippe laurent bonjour merci beaucoup
jour être avec nous est le maire udi de
sault candidat donc à la présidence de
cette association des maires de france
et on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes
pour une interview en partenariat avec
la presse quotidienne régionale
représentée par stéphane bern et bonjour
stéphane bonjour stéphane qui dirige le
bureau parisien du journal ouest france
on commence avec la crise sanitaire
évidemment que j'espère ans puisqu'on le
voit le taux d'incidence remonte ça y
est le nombre de cas remontent lors de
la crise sanitaire il ya quelques mois
vous avez vous aviez souhaité rang de
masque obligatoire dans votre commune de
sour au toqué par la justice les maires
ont l'avion est en première ligne durant
cette crise sanitaire est ce que le
gouvernement on a tiré les leçons en
partie mais en partie seulement il y a
toujours
évidemment des des mesures qui sont
imposés qui ne sont pas forcément
toujours adaptée au territoire de
travaillons en bonne intelligence
généralement avec les préfets ça se
passe bien mais encore faut-il que les
préfets eux mêmes est un peu de marge de
manoeuvre ce qui n'est pas quoi bah
c'est pas toujours le cas ainsi pas sur
le cas on l'a vu et vous avez rappelé
donc là la mesure que j'avais prises
avec le port d'une protection on parlait
pas de masque et il n'avait pas d'effort
que c'était au mois d'avril
2020 et bien on a vu que quelques mois
après et bien cette mesure a été
généralisé et si je l'avais fait c'est
parce que il y avait dans ma ville
beaucoup de gens dans la rue piétonne
parce qu'il ya énormément de commerce et
il y avait vraiment une concentration de
personnes et il y avait évidemment à
danger et il fallait absolument le faire
les coûts mais vous en coûter les
mesures prises à l'échelle de la ville
et est ce que la question de la
compensation par l'état et est toujours
d'actualité alors les mesures prises ont
coûté au
village à des masques de l'ugel de
protection etc il ya eu surtout un
manque à gagner important parce que les
équipes ont été souvent juste le manque
à gagner qui est des plus avantageux que
voilà et nous nous estimons
l'association des maires de france que
le coût global pour les communes sur les
trois ans en 2020 2021 2022 est de
l'ordre de 5 à 6 milliards d'euros le
coût global le manque à gagner est le
coût 1 donc cinq à six milliards d'euros
la compensation n'a été que partiel pour
un certain nombre de services notamment
pour les transports en commun mais pas
du tout pour le manque à gagner sur sur
la fermeture des crèches la fermeture de
des services périscolaires ça reste un
sujet avec l'état
cette semaine ce sera un sujet houleux
nous l'évoquerons d'ailleurs lors de
deux du grand débat sur les finances qui
aura lieu jeudi matin et puis il y a
aussi les centres de vaccination nous
avons maintenant nos centres de
vaccination sont ouverts depuis près
d'un an et à centres de vaccination ça
coûte à peu près entre 5 et 10 euros par
habitant et par an donc c'est quelque
chose qui représente
une monstre une masse d'argent
importante pour une ville comme la
mienne c'est à peu près en est un c'est
à peu près cent mille euros sur l'année
philippe laurent on va parler de votre
candidature à la tête de cette
association des maires de france
première condition à 500 pourquoi vous
avez décidé de vous présenter à la
présidence de la mf qu'est ce que vous
voulez un carrelet écoutez moi l
association des maires de france c'est
une grande partie de ma vie déjà je suis
au bureau de l'aimf depuis 20 ans j'y
suis rentré avec jean paul delevoye donc
il ya déjà un certain temps dès lors que
j'ai été élu maire j'ai présidé la
commission des finances pendant
longtemps je suis aujourd'hui secrétaire
j'étais vice-président de jacques
pélissard jetaient aux dires du
secrétaire général avec françois baroin
depuis sept ans et je pense bien
connaître à la fois les dossiers puis
aussi bien connaître toute cette cette
maille des associations départementales
où je me rends très souvent plus d'une
centaine de déplacements ces dernières
années dans les associations
départementales parce que c'est là que
les maires expriment leurs
préoccupations leurs propositions donc
je suis j'aime beaucoup d'ailleurs ses
déplacements qui permet de vraiment
sentir le pouls de cette population très
particulière des maires de france
indispensable à la vie notre pays alors
moi je souhaite simplement que la mf
continue évidemment les combats qui sont
les siens sur la décentralisation sur
sur l'autonomie fiscale sur
la protection aussi des élus qui est
échoué en arrière à venir d'important
donc je souhaite évidemment continuer
tous ses combats je pense que la mf aura
une voix plus forte si elle surplombe en
fait le débat partisan et le débat
politique celle surplombe c'est dire si
elle sait porter la voix des mères à la
fois avec les fera en partenariat avec
les forces économiques syndicales
associatives si elle est plus présente
au parlement qu'elle mené surtout depuis
l'abandon du cumul des mandats et si
elle entretient avec le gouvernement et
bien sûr des relations exigeante mais
des relations quand même parce que il
faut que les textes avance il faut que
nous soyons force de proposition voilà
un peu est ce que vous vous seriez
présent c est ce qu on va revenir et
finalement sur tous ces sujets en détail
mais sur vous pour bien comprendre le
sens mais votre candidature est ce que
vous seriez présenter quoi qu'il arrive
ou est-ce que c'est clairement le fait
que françois baron ans soutiennent david
lisnard qui vous à présent penser à vous
présentez pas de tv comme ça que ça
s'est passé au mois de mai dernier dans
un tête-à-tête avec françois baroin je
lui ai dit que s'il était candidat à
nouveau je le soutiendrai et je
continuerai à travailler avec lui mais
que s'il n'était pas candidat je serai
candidat compte tenu de ce que je viens
de dire pour incarner justement une
forme aussi de continuité des combats
avec peut-être une ouverture un peu
différente de l'association des maires
de france dont je lui ai dit clairement
bah manifestement c'est le message n'est
pas bien passé donc
vous regretter la méthode vous regretter
qu'il
a mis le siège les méthodes la méthode
n'a pas été la bonne et il eût fallu aux
atouts le mois que les dirigeants
actuels de l'association des maires de
france puis s'être concertés et qu'on
puisse en parler par exemple au début de
l'été bon ça ne s'est pas passé comme ça
on a appris cette décision et le soutien
à mon concurrent la fin du mois d'août
donc c'est une méthode qui ne paraît pas
tout à fait approprié à la situation bon
voilà après président sortant va il se
prononce il soutient un autre candidat a
bien j'en prends acte est-ce que c'est
précisément cette méthode qui vous a
empêché par exemple de trouver un
arrangement avec david 10 la lie cela à
faire une liste commune comme c'est
comme celle longtemps été la tradition
au sein de la nfl
il y aurait pu peut-être y avoir en
effet une liste commune mais vous savez
ce que vous avez essayé ça et c'était
possible
le dépôt des candidatures s'est lui
septembre à il fallait donc régler ça
entre le 25 août et lui septembre c'est
un peu court donc a pas eu de recherches
d'accord n'ont ils pas une recherche
d'accords il eût fallu que la question
soit abordée dès le début du mois de
juillet moi pour ma part j'ai cherché à
joindre à nouveau françois baroin pour
essayer de discuter avec lui de voir
dans quel état d'esprit d'été début
juillet mais moi je n'ai appris le fait
qu'il ne souhaitait pas se représenter
uniquement à la fin du mois d'août donc
ya pas eu le temps de cet accord est de
toute façon lorsque je me suis déclaré
candidat le 26 août est un jour demain
de la déclaration de françois baroin et
bien il y avait déjà une liste de bureau
qui était à peu près constitué
notamment enfin à parité comme on dit
bon gauche droite enfin si encore ces
mots là peuvent encore avoir un sens
s'agissant des moeurs justement puisque
vous ne vous nous parlez de l'équilibré
gauche droite vous entendez les
reproches qui vous sont faits il ya
beaucoup de maires sur votre liste qui
sont proches du pouvoir actuel proche
des manuels macway ce que votre votre
élection si elle a lieu au risque de
nuire à l'indépendance de l'association
des maires ont pas du tout pas du tout
j'ai été je lui ai dit tout à l'heure
que je continuerai à mener les combats
de la mfg publié un petit livre début
septembre qui dis ce que je pense de
l'action de l'actuel gouvernement et du
président de la république en matière de
territoire donc je suis très critique je
suis très critique parce que il y a
véritablement un problème de culture
entre la haute administration qui qui en
fait irrigué la pensée du président de
la république et
et la question de la décentralisation du
rapport aux pouvoirs locaux etc donc
c'est une question de votre élection si
elle a lieu c'est pas la mainmise de
l'exécutif de l'association des maires
non du tout absolument pas ça je récuse
absolument cela d'ailleurs je trouve que
c'est quand même un peu méprisant de
dire cela encore une fois vingt ans de
combat la mf entendre cela
trouve que c'est considérer que tous les
maires qui ont bien voulu m'accompagner
dans cette aventure serait donc des gens
qui sont manipulables mais non les
maires ne sont pas manipulables vous
venez d'évoquer le livre que vous avez
publié est ce que vous pouvez nous dire
un petit peu en quelques en quelques
mots comment vous avez fait campagne
pour 7 pour cette élection et comment
vous continuez à faire campagne
alors vous savez cette élection à la
présidence de l'association des maires
de france qui s'accompagne de l'élection
de la liste du bureau et des listes et
comité directeur comme vous le savez il
ya trois élections parallèles c'est un
peu comme une grande élection
sénatoriale c'est à dire qu'en réalité
il y à des électeurs qui sont au fait
des choses ce sont les maires donc ce
sont des gens qui qui qui comprennent et
qui est qu'ils sont à même de faire la
part des choses dans le choix qu'ils
font et de ce point de vue
il faut aller voir allez allez les voir
sur le terrain il faut moi j'ai fait
près de 30 des placements dans les
départements avec soit l'occasion
d'assemblées générales d'associations
départementales soit à l'occasion de
rencontres plus informelle on a fait
aussi pas mal de visio avec une dizaine
de maires dans chaque département on a
constitué un réseau dans chaque là aussi
dans chaque département donc c'est une
campagne de messages et une campagne de
dialogue c'est une campagne de contact
quasi personnel avec si on pouvait
accuser c'est très personnalisé mais sur
quels points précis ou sur quel argument
vous pensez pouvoir faire la différence
avec de laetitia alors justement c'est
vous différencie examiner cet arrêt
différence et le positionnement de la mf
c'est clair c'est le positionnement de
la mf moi je prône encore une fois une à
mf qui soit présente en tant qu elle
même qui porte la voie des mers et pour
la porter le plus fortement possible
pour avoir la plus forte influence je
suis convaincu qu'il nous faut
travailler avec toutes les autres
associations d'élus vous savez qu'elle
m'a beaucoup d'associations et du locaux
et il faut donc travailler non pas ce
regroupement mais cette fédération a des
pouvoirs locaux que que je prône depuis
depuis longtemps avec les maires ruraux
avec m et rurbains avec les
intercommunalités avec les petites
villes et villes moyennes également
continuer le travail que nous avions
déjà engagé avec les départements et les
régions et donc cette fédération des
pouvoirs locaux je me semble-t-il elle
doit s'abstenir totalement des autres
contingences politiques et des autres
élections politiques qui disent qu'ils
sont autre chose faut pas que l'élection
de la mf soit prise en otage par exemple
par l'élection présidentielle de l'année
prochaine vous bien ça s'est réglé sa
dette c'est le cas oui je pense oui est
ce que parce qu'elle est trop partisan
parce qu'il ya la mise en avant des
partis politiques il y avait mise en
avant des écuries présidentielles et je
pense pourquoi il ne ferait plus que
vous et pourquoi les gens qui sont
chères est président les gens ils sont
sur le départ éclair ça me paraît clair
que par exemple tout l'état-major d'un
grand parti de droite se prononce bien
et le soutien voilà moi je n'ai pas de
soutien d'états majors de partis j'ai le
soutien d'un grand nombre de maires et
de beaucoup de présidents d'associations
départementales et je pense que ce sont
des soutiens plus efficace et plus utile
à la fois pour les élections mais aussi
pour l'avenir excusez le sentiment que
l'association des maires de france
s'était refermée sur elle-même ces
dernières années tout à fait c'est tout
à fait c'est un peu ce sentiment là
d'ailleurs je m'en suis ouvert à
plusieurs reprises avec les dirigeants
de la mf pendant plusieurs années
notamment j'ai beaucoup regretté que la
mf est distendu ses liens avec toutes
les associations d'élus parce que
finalement d'une manière le gouvernement
s'est servi de cette de ses liens
distendus sont desservies en
établissement des liens privilégiés avec
telle ou telle association est
finalement en mettant un peu de côté la
mfr présente pourtant ces dernières
années c'était les années territoire
unis par exemple il ya eu à vis des
conditions il ya des alliances des
démarches communes très fort ça c'est du
côté des départements et des régions
mais à côté de ça il ya aussi tout
l'ensemble des associations du bloc
local comme je disais tout à l'heure
france urbaine donc c'est plutôt là
c'est là qu'est le problème et c'est ça
qu'il faut recoudre et je pense être
tout à fait à même de le faire parce que
je connais chacune et chacun des
dirigeants de ces associations etc
eux-mêmes le souhaitent et qu' ils me
feront confiance pour le faire on va
passer au dossier que vous aurez à gérer
c'est tout élu président vous êtes l'un
des spécialistes des finances dans cette
association des maires on l'a dit c'est
l'un des points de crispation entre
l'état et les maires la question des
finances la question des compensations
en a parlé tout à l'heure les maires qui
dénoncent la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation et à françois baroin les
excès peut-être la pire réformes en
matière de décentralisation est ce que
vous souhaitez revenir dessus ben moi je
ne veux pas revenir dessus celui qui
peut revenir dessus c
est ce que vous pensez que c'est
possible politiquement de revenir je
pense que nous ne pouvons pas échapper
nous sommes à la croisée des chemins
nous ne pouvons pas échapper aujourd'hui
à une réflexion approfondie sur ce
qu'est véritablement la décentralisation
et sur le lien qui lie à entre
décentralisation responsabiliser son
local et autonomie fiscale on ne peut
pas échapper à ce qu'avait d'ailleurs je
note avec intérêt que pas mal
universitaire aussi ont cette réflexion
là et donc ça ça me conforte dans cette
conviction et comment
mais supprimée on crée un nouvel impôt
local pour compenser non pas forcément
on discute et on voit comment on peut
par exemple partager les grands impôts
nationaux entre l'état d'un côté les
collectivités locales de l'autre mais en
donnant une capacité de modulation
collectivités locales pour la part qui
leur revient là aujourd'hui c'est pas le
cas aujourd'hui on vous dit on partait
de la tva entre l'état et les régions
mais non on partage le produit de tva
n'y a pas de possibilités pour telle ou
telle région de faire varier même à la
marge loto or ça c'est ça la
responsabilisation fiscale et elle va
encore une fois c'est un un corollaire
c'est une condition indispensable à la
responsabilisation politique
la sécurité les élus sont menacés on a
vu que les agressions des élus notamment
des élus locaux avaient avaient triplé
ces dernières années vous et gérald
darmanin mise de l'intérieur qui demande
aux préfets de renforcer la surveillance
des permanences voir des domiciles
privés des élus est ce que l'état ait
suffisamment présent à vos côtés
alors nous avons des partenariats avec
l'état notamment par exemple quelque
chose qui fonctionne très bien qui est
le travail que nous faisons avec la
gendarmerie pour former les élus à des
situations de crise ou à des situations
de tension avec les administrés ça
fonctionne très bien et les landes on
sent très satisfait nous avons
d'excellents rapports avec notamment la
gendarmerie nationale sur ce sujet ce
que ce qui ce qui nous apparaît nous
comme étant comme posant vraiment
problème c'est la lenteur de la justice
dans les sujets qui concernent les
violences notamment faite au maire mais
ça serait la même chose pour les
violents de fait à toute personne
dépositaire de l'autorité un bien sûr un
par exemple quelque chose que nous ne
comprenons pas et qui kinois rhin c'est
le fait que
notre collègue de signes à vous souvenez
c'était au mois d'août 2010 9 qui a
trouvé la mort
avec bon
les gens sont connus des coupables sont
identifiés alors après il faut éclairer
bien les circonstances de cette affaire
mais en tout cas les coupables ceux qui
étaient sur place ils sont connus et
bien le jugement n'a toujours pas eu
lieu c'est plus de deux ans après et ça
c'est quelque chose que nous ne
comprenons pas et pourtant des
instructions ont semble-t-il été donnée
donc on a un vrai sujet avec ces
lenteurs de la justice sur ce type
d'affaires mais d'une manière générale
d'ailleurs un et qui sont liées me
semble-t-il n'ont pas une volonté des
magistrats mais vraiment un manque de
moyens qu'elle et ça c'est vraiment le
sujet numéro un donc plus que de
protection c'est d'exemplarité vous
épouse en pleurs étaient tout à fait
l'autre sujet c'est la décentralisation
évidemment l'association des maires qui
entend faire de ce congrès à celui d'un
appel fort à la renégociation des
relations entre état et collectivités
s'adosse traduire comment concrètement
alors il y a un projet de loi qui est en
cours des discussions qui est déjà été
examinée au sénat nous avons beaucoup
travaillé avec moi c'est ce qu'on
appelle 3ds il y a 6 pour vous pour les
élus locaux qui sert à rien on ne peut
pas dire ça il est utile parce qu'il ya
des dispositions qui nous conviennent
mais en fait il est surtout il marque il
est surtout marquant parce qu'il ne
contient pas malheureusement nous avons
donc souhaité et le sénat a complété ce
texte dans la mesure du possible et nous
verrons ce que fera l'assemblée
nationale ça c'est important c'est un
des dossiers urgents de la mf qu'elle a
d'ailleurs commencé à traiter avec les
rapporteurs à l'assemblée nationale mais
ce qui nous ce qui nous ce qui nous
paraît important c'est que nous ayons
une pleine et entière application de ce
qu'on appelle vous savez le principe de
subsidiarité c'est-à-dire tout ce qui
peut être réglé au niveau local par des
décisions locales doit l'être au niveau
local par des décisions locales ça c'est
un sujet et c'est un principe essentiel
par exemple lorsque on a quand même fait
application de sa part nécessité l'état
a été obligé de le faire les centres de
vaccination dont parlait tout à l'heure
on a ouvert des centres de vaccination
nous avons su le faire avec toute
personnelle avec nos médecins les
médecins du territoire avec les locaux
dont nous disposons on ouvert en
quelques jours des centres de
vaccination à peu près partout ça a été
on l'a fait finalement fin sans heurt
sans sans crise on l'a fait parce que ça
nous savons le faire et ben voilà donc
on a évidemment notamment dans tout ce
qui concerne les questions logistiques
au sens large nous pensons que nous
devrions avoir une forme de
responsabilité supplémentaire en matière
de gestion de la santé fiq cela veut
dire une loi clairement une loi de
décentralisation dans le prochain
quinquennat mesure c'est indispensable
ah oui c'est indispensable c'est
indispensable parce que c'est il faut
que ce soit une loi qui est à contenu
politique la décentralisation s'est pas
uniquement de la gestion c'est aussi un
pilier d'un projet de société c'est
aussi responsabiliser
les acteurs locaux au niveau local et
c'est pour ça que la fiscalisation
qu'enfin la fiscalité en tout cas est
vraiment important tout ne passe pas par
la loi ça passe aussi par de bonnes
relations avec les représentants de
l'état dans les territoires donc le
fameux couple maire préfet est ce que
est ce que là il ya des délais il ya des
choses à améliorer en la matière vous
avez raison je ne passe pas par la loi
mais malheureusement la loi elle est
très précise elle va très loin à chaque
fois ci elle la loi était une forme
d'encadrement qui interdisent de faire
telle ou telle chose mais qui permet
tout le reste ça serait pas pareil là
aujourd'hui nous avons des lois mais
d'une manière générale qui se sont
beaucoup trop faim qui parle beaucoup
trop qui vont beaucoup trop dans le
détail ce qui fait que les marges de
manoeuvre soit du pouvoir réglementaire
soit des préfets dans l'application sont
limitées alors je suis je siège suis
vice-président du conseil des normes et
nous voyons tous les textes
réglementaires passé dans ce conseil et
nous voyons bien que les marges de
manoeuvre sont très très sont très
limités donc en effet tout le tout
devrait pas passer par la loi mais
malheureusement c'est une dérive de
notre système légistique c'est comme ça
et d'ailleurs tout le monde le regrette
qu'il faut aussi corriger et ça c'est
aussi une responsabilité
des au plus haut niveau de l'état
philippe laurent emmanuel macron viendra
jeudi conclure votre congrès est ce que
vous attendez du discours du chef de
l'état et comment vous qualifier ce
quinquennat dans les relations entre les
maires et le gouvernement alors le
évidemment la visite du ponant la
république est toujours un événement
et hélas c'est un événement d'autant
plus que c'est le dernier congrès avant
l'élection présidentielle et que ce sera
le premier accueil par le nouveau
président quel qu'il soit donc
voilà c'est une ambiance tout à fait
tout à fait particulière et progrès
physiques pour des mères nouvellement
élu et promis vous avez raison au
premier congrès aussi pour d'aimables
nouvellement élu en 2020 et donc c'est
un congrès qui est vraiment très très
particulier de ce point de vue avec à
mon sens peut-être pas mal de subtilité
qui qui qui seront maintenant mais parce
que voilà moi je pense que le président
de la république d'abord nous nous
attendons bien sûr toujours
une reconnaissance par le président de
la république parce que
ya pas de reconnaissance il ya une
reconnaissance mais on sent qu'elle est
parfois un peu forcé il faut qu' il faut
que ce soit ça vienne plus des tripes si
je puis dire voilà c'est ce marché voilà
un qui contient les barres allemand il
sans doute eu sans doute mais c'est un
peu pareil voilà non je pense que voilà
cette reconnaissance par le président de
la république évidemment quelque chose
d'important vous savez la république
c'est
depuis longtemps c'est l'état et la
commune 1 voilà ce sur cette relation
entre l'état et la commune c'est une
relation très forte on ne peut pas aller
les maires ne sont pas contre l'état les
maires font partie de l'état les maires
font partie de l'état mais il ne veut
pas non plus être simplement des sous
traitants
de l'administration d'état et je veux
distinguer d'ailleurs les ministres les
politiques si vous voulez et puis
l'administration moi je crois qu'il ya
une grande évolution de grande
révolution culturelle à opérer dans une
partie de l'administration centrale et
ça ça c'est la responsabilité du
président la république il n'y a que lui
qui puisse opérer cette révolution
culturelle si vous êtes élu comment la
mf va s'impliquer dans la campagne
présidentielle est ce que il va y avoir
des prises de position autre que vous
allez recevoir les candidats comment
vous allez faire comment vous souhaitez
que ça se passe en tout cas alors si je
suis élu président de l'association des
maires de france j'ai déjà dit que pour
ma part je ne prendrai position pour
aucun des candidats en tant que
président de l'association des maires de
france en revanche naturellement et
l'association des maires de france et
probablement et je l'espère en
collaboration avec l'ensemble des
associations d'élus département région
mais aussi les associations du bloc du
bloc communal compte comme on dit eh
bien nous je proposerai que nous
établissions une plateforme commune de
proposition et je proposerai aussi que
nous auditionnons comme l'avion fait
d'aller en 2017 chacune et chacun des
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
une fois que ceux-ci ont été désignés
enfin oui ont reçu leur parrainage est
donc là ça sera des auditions communes
où il y aura plateforme commune et
chacun 16 éditions je pense que ce sera
plutôt chacun ses auditions mais ça
n'empêche pas une plateforme commune et
nous aurons ça donc probablement au mois
de mars quoi donc quelques quelques
semaines avant avant avant l'élection ça
c'est l'apport que la mfp peut faire
pour à la fois l'ensemble des maires et
puis pourquoi pas l'ensemble des
citoyens parce que j'espère que nous
pourrons donc diffuser cela de manière
très large
cet apport à l'occasion de ces élections
présidentielles dont je souhaite
éminemment que la question de la
décentralisation soit un des sujets
abordés et dernière question à peu près
une dernière question n'ont pas ou
futures au maire de la mf mais au maire
président dit au président pardon de la
mf mais homer udi que vous êtes ce que
vous allez regretter que les
républicains exclu d y ait le sens d'une
manière générale lors de leurs primaires
vous allez allez vous satisfait à ce
trait aux relations dans ma vie
politique j'ai eu de nombreuses fois à
regretter que cette famille politique
dans laquelle je compte par ailleurs
beaucoup d'amis beaucoup de gens que
j'apprécie et que cette famille
politique est toujours tendance à faire
preuve d'un peu d'arrogance notamment
vis-à-vis des centristes voilà donc je
pense qu'il aurait été préférable que il
y ait cette primaire ouverte comme
d'ailleurs ça avait été le cas en 2000
en 2016 1 avec un grand nombre de
votants maintenant c'est leur choix
voilà nous lui dit vous le savez nous
n'ont pas de candidat à cette élection
présidentielle merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]